en este vídeo vamos a enfocarnos en la
estéreo química del bien del lado
derecho tenemos el bien y del lado
izquierdo
tenemos el bien o filo entonces primero
vamos a dibujar nuestro producto sin
preocuparnos ahorita por la estéreo
química sabemos que una reacción de ti
el saler consiste en un movimiento
concertado de 6 electrones bic así que
estos electrones se mueven hacia acá
formando un enlace entre estos dos
carbonos estos electrones bi se mueven
hacia acá para formar un enlace entre
estos dos carbonos y finalmente estos
electrones se mueven hacia abajo vamos a
dibujar nuestro producto sin tomar en
cuenta la exterior química aquí tenemos
dos enlaces
y después tenemos dos grupos metilo y
luego voy a abreviar
estos grupos de esther como co2 m
y por acá co2 m
y tenemos este al 'chino' como de no
filo porque así no tenemos que
preocuparnos por la estéreo química en
estos dos carbonos pero si hay que tomar
en cuenta la estéreo química en estos
dos carbonos que originalmente vienen
del lleno vamos a analizar con más
detalle la estructura del bien observen
que este es un día no trans trans porque
este doble enlace se encuentra trans al
igual que éste pero vamos a enfocarnos
en los sustituye entes internos los
hidrógenos si analizamos la fotografía
observen que del lado izquierdo aquí
tenemos los hidrógenos internos y cuando
formamos un enlace entre estos dos
carbonos y entre estos
observen que estos hidrógenos que están
unidos a carbonos con hibridación sp2
del lado derecho
estos dos carbonos ahora tienen una
hibridación sp3 así que estos hidrógenos
que son sustituyen tests internos
terminan hacia arriba en el producto si
observamos el anillo desde esta
perspectiva esos dos hidrógenos se
encuentran hacia nosotros vamos a
dibujar eso aquí tenemos nuestro anillo
y después tenemos dos dobles enlaces
luego aquí tenemos un esther co2 m y por
acá co2 m y después en estos dos
carbonos tenemos un hidrógeno hacia
nosotros así que podemos dibujar una
cuña aquí tenemos uno
aquí tenemos otro hidrógeno hacia
nosotros ok ahora analicemos los
sustituye entes externos estos son
nuestros sustituye entes externos que en
este caso son dos grupos metilo y en la
fotografía corresponden a las esferas
amarillas
ahora cuando estos dos carbonos pasan de
una hibridación sp2 a sp3 observen lo
que pasa con los grupos metilo si los
sustituyen tests internos terminan hacia
arriba bueno entonces los sustituye
entes externos quedan hacia abajo estos
son nuestros grupos metilo así que al
observar el anillo desde esta
perspectiva los grupos metilo quedan
lejos de nosotros así que los podemos
representar claro con una línea punteada
este grupo metilo está lejos de nosotros
al igual que éste
para el siguiente problema tenemos el
mismo de no filo pero miren tenemos un
día en o diferente
este es el ciclo penn está bien y
observen que los dobles enlaces se
encuentran en posición cis entonces para
que ocurra la reacción de piel sal der
hay que mover 6 electrones para estos
electrones que se mueven hacia acá para
formar un enlace entre estos dos
carbonos estos electrones se mueven
hacia acá para formar otro enlace entre
estos dos carbonos y finalmente estos
electrones se mueven hacia acá vamos a
dibujar el producto
este es nuestro anillo vamos a resaltar
los electrones estos electrones en rojo
se movieron aquí después estos
electrones vi en azul se movieron acá y
finalmente los electrones vi en rosa se
movieron aquí ahora aquí tenemos un ch 2
entonces nos va a quedar una especie de
puente y también nos falta colocar los
grupos esther en este carbono
tenemos un 0 2 m
y en este carbono también tenemos un 0 2
m
esta es una forma de dibujar el producto
pero para tomar en cuenta la estéreo
química vamos a ver la fotografía
observen que el ch todos con el que
formamos el puente corresponde a este
carbono así que estos enlaces son los
que nos ayudan a formar el puente
son los sustituye entes internos
recordemos que los sustituye en tests
internos terminan hacia arriba así que
cuando se forma este enlace en color
rojo que se forma entre este carbono y
este carbono bueno miren corresponde a
este enlace y también se forma este
enlace azul entre este carbono y este
carbono y corresponde a este enlace así
que el puente sh2 termina hacia arriba y
podemos dibujar este producto desde
nuestra perspectiva trataré de dibujarlo
esta es otra forma de dibujar nuestro
producto aquí tenemos los dobles enlaces
por acá tenemos co2 m y por acá tenemos
el otro co2 m
y bueno ya dijimos que el puente del ch
2 se encuentra arriba
y aquí tenemos el mismo bien o filo del
problema anterior pero observen que esta
vez en nuestro día no tenemos una
conformación 6 en este doble enlace pero
este doble enlace es trans primero
movamos nuestros 6 electrones para estos
electrones se mueven hacia acá para
formar un enlace entre estos dos
carbonos estos electrones se mueven
hacia acá para formar un enlace entre
estos dos carbonos y estos electrones se
mueven hacia abajo vamos a dibujar
nuestro producto aquí tenemos el anillo
y tenemos dos dobles enlaces
ahora vamos a poner los grupos esther
aquí tenemos un 0 2 m y aquí tenemos
otro 0 2 m
ahora vamos a pensar en los sustituyen
test primero analicemos los
constituyentes internos
aquí tenemos un hidrógeno y un grupo
metilo y si analizamos la fotografía
aquí tenemos el hidrógeno y aquí tenemos
el metilo entonces cuando se forman los
enlaces entre estos dos carbonos y estos
dos carbonos los sustituye en tests
internos terminan hacia arriba miren
aquí está el hidrógeno y aquí está el
metilo y si observáramos el producto
desde esta perspectiva esos grupos están
hacia nosotros entonces el grupo metilo
está unido a este carbono que
corresponde a este carbono aquí tenemos
un grupo metilo hacia nosotros que lo
podemos representar con una cuña y en
este carbono que corresponde a éste
tenemos un hidrógeno hacia nosotros así
que podemos dibujar otra cuña aquí
tenemos uno
ok ahora vamos con los sustituye entes
externos observen que este hidrógeno y
este grupo metilo son los sustituye
entes externos y en la fotografía aquí
tenemos el hidrógeno y aquí está el
grupo metilo podemos ver que por ejemplo
este hidrógeno quedó hacia abajo así que
vamos a representarlo con una línea
punteada y recuerden los sustituye entes
externos terminan hacia abajo por eso
este grupo metilo se encuentra hacia
abajo en relación a este hidrógeno aquí
tenemos un grupo metilo y qué pasaría si
tomamos el hielo y lo observaremos desde
otra perspectiva bueno veamos el
siguiente vídeo
este es el hielo y las esferas amarillas
son los grupos metilo si lo rotamos
podemos ver que ahora este metilo es un
sustituye ente interno y este metilo es
un sustituyendo
externa como vimos en el vídeo este bien
no es el mismo que este solo que en otra
perspectiva si movemos nuestros 6
electrones pib para formar los enlaces
entre carbonos como ya vimos vamos a
dibujar el producto aquí tenemos el
anillo y tenemos dos dobles enlaces
después tenemos los grupos esther co2 m
y co2 m
ahora veamos los sustituyen test
internos
aquí tenemos un hidrógeno y un grupo
metilo y acuérdense los sustituyen tests
internos terminan hacia arriba entonces
a este hidrógeno y a este grupo metilo
los vamos a representar con una cuña en
este carbono
tenemos una cuña para el hidrógeno y en
este carbono tenemos otra cuña para el
grupo metilo
vamos con los sustituye entes externos
tenemos un grupo metilo y un hidrógeno y
acuérdense los sustituye entes externos
terminan hacia abajo así que el grupo
metilo queda lejos de nosotros ch3 y el
hidrógeno también queda lejos de
nosotros también lo representamos con
una línea punteada este es nuestro
producto y miren cuando teníamos el
lleno en esta forma este fue el producto
entonces cuál será la relación entre
esta molécula y esta bueno son
enantiómero así que en realidad esta
reacción nos da un par de enantiómero